-Behra pulls up next
to you, challenging.
You're even.
But two objects cannot occupy
the same point in space
at the same moment in time.
Behra doesn't lift.
The corner races at you.
You have perhaps
a crisis of identity.
Am I a sportsman
or a competitor?
How will the French think of me
if I run Behra into a tree?
You lift, he passes.
He won, you lose.
-We're back with Adam Driver,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a clip from "Ferrari."
I feel like
when I was a kid and, like,
went through an era where I was
obsessed with things
like Ferraris and cars,
it never connected with me
that, of course, Ferrari
was somebody's last name,
who just, like, had the idea
to make cars like this.
Did you know much
about Enzo Ferrari
before you started doing this?
-No. Oddly the only --
my first --
I think in retrospect,
looking back,
that my first intro to Ferraris
was from Michael's
"Miami Vice" because my dad
was a big "Miami Vice" fan.
Of course, he has the Ferrari
in that, that he blew up,
and that was kind of his intro
to Enzo at the time.
They had
I think a phone correspondence.
They may have met one time,
but they blew up a replica car
and he's like, "Why don't you
have the real thing?"
So, anyway, but I knew of them
as drivable works of art.
But, you know,
growing up in Indiana,
there was -- or just anywhere,
they were out of my price range.
-Right.
-Yeah.
-You wouldn't, like, go out to
the main road
and say like, "Let's see
if we see a Ferrari today."
-Yeah, yeah.
Show me the 355.
-Yeah. Did you --
And I did not realize
that he basically --
he wanted to race cars,
and he only sold them
to sort of fund the racing.
-Yeah, he was a racer first.
And at this point
that we find him in 1957,
in this three-month period,
he was going bankrupt
because he was more interested
in racing cars
and kind of almost resented
the customer part of being,
you know,
running a car company
and, you know, was spending
all of his money on that
and not so much
commercial vehicles.
And also the game was changing.
It was -- TV was becoming
more a part of racing.
So he was more incentivized to,
you know, you win on Sunday,
you sell cars on Monday.
-Must not have been
a terrible place.
Obviously when you travel
for a film
and you're away
from your family,
not ideal, but being in Italy
must have been outstanding.
-Yeah, being away anywhere
without my family
is outstanding
but especially with Italy...
[ Laughter ]
Actually, my family
was with me.
-Oh, good.
-So it was...
-Win-win. Or win-lose.
-Yeah.
Everyone's like, "You do
a lot of movies in Italy."
I'm like, "Isn't it obvious?"
-Yeah, yeah, yeah,
that's very smart.
-Yeah.
-Even the clip we showed,
one of many scenes
at a dinner table,
which feels very Italian...
-Yeah.
-And I would imagine
they want to get
the authenticity of the food
when you're doing those
dinner table scenes.
-Oh, I didn't think about that.
But yeah.
-Like, if there was, like,
just, like a big thing
of Wonder Bread, you'd be like,
"What are they doing?"
-Yeah, yeah. I would know
that something is wrong.
Yeah, but Michael is very,
food aside,
he is relentless about
authenticity in his films.
In this film, the barbershop
where he goes
is the barbershop he went to.
The guy who was cutting my hair
is the grandson of the guy
who actually cut Enzo's hair.
You know, he brought in replica
or the real Maseratis
and some Testarossa.
They would do scans
of the ones
that were historical vehicles
and duplicate them.
The ones that he did
bring in that
were like $70 million Ferraris.
He would attach seven mikes to
them and drive them in tunnels
because you can't
replicate the sound.
It has to be in the place,
you know.
He's relentless.
So I have no doubt that
Wonder Bread
was not part of the dinner.
-It'd be really funny
if they were like,
"We have to use Wonder Bread
because you made us drive
a $70 million car."
-Right, right.
-"We don't have money left
for good bread, Michael."
It's a wonderful film.
I should note
the rest of the cast
is great as well.
And it's always such a delight
to see you, Adam.
-Thank you so much
for having me.
-Happy holidays
to you and your family.
Adam Driver. "Ferrari," theaters
on Christmas day.
Stick around. We'll be
right back with Gary Gulman.